[Music]
today we're shooting the video piece on
how Andy and I got from Los Angeles to
San Diego for comic-con and of course
the reveal is that we drove down mad
max-style
[Music]
fury road hey what are we doing today
it is a Mad Max parody or so I am told
as I have not seen the movie yet I Drive
a truck
Andy's driving the truck that I'm
suspending from Andy not a good driver
also an early morning drinker the
sunglasses looked really good
I know those you occasionally if you
look like it like Helena Bonham Carter
open to spa endurance first cup have you
seen room with a view look at that truck
I'm gonna be strapped to the top of that
Andy's gonna be driving it no actually
when you're her man it I can't drive it
out because I don't think so because
they know they know hi I'm Eric Allard
and I'm the special effects coordinator
here on the Conan show so the way we
start a project like that of course see
the movie and we get research material
we have good pictures of war wagon the
war wagon itself I designed that all of
the elements of that on AutoCAD the idea
is to pick up the key sort of
architectural features of something like
that take credit first I designed this
big steel structure here then this then
we design the speaker's and then the
ducting all of those various components
are broken out in the individual
drawings which are given to the various
people who are building and we had a
parking lot on the Warner Brothers lot
where we had a crane and you just
assembled the thing it was a four day
project
[Music]
you can't drive too close to the power
lines because it will mark the your
electricity would arc and we're electing
you so I I'm not supposed to go too
closely to the power lines is the kind
of thing I told my wife about afterwards
my Foreman Paul staples is also a guitar
maker so that was convenient he went to
a pawn shop got a bass and a guitar and
we cut him up whole space let's built
this that weighs 50 pounds that's that's
why Paul so big that isn't because he's
got to be able to hold we good this is a
flame thrower edge and a flame thrower
comes out at this end this is all
decorations you see those spark plugs
high pressure lines that go to a flame
thrower the back is a steel plate or the
steel bar so that will support itself
really heavy this is how he did it right
here he would hit that and it would go
so he was actually shooting it we
weren't doing it by remote
you know Conan hanging 20 feet in the
air off a traveling truck with a live
flamethrower in his hand there were
really no tricks to it other than Conan
was game
he got into harness and he got up there
and did it and he did an amazing job
I've done a lot of this sort of thing
Conan sucked it up man he really did a
great job and not one complaint really
good work some concern about the wind
kicking up it already has and that when
we shoot the flames out of the guitar
the flames will be buffeted by the winds
back into my face and burn my flesh off
that could happen there's about a 40
percent chance of that occurring but
I've been told that 40% good
[Music]
okay we're done in the desert with our
Mad Max hold open for comic-con It's A
Wrap real sex episode seven